- You brought a clip of
your wife, actually, right?
- I did, so they asked
me, your staff said,
"What's it like, marriage for 40 years?
"How do you make it interesting?"
I don't know if I make it
interesting as I do annoying
and my wife, I'll show you.
I brought this clip because
she got really mad at me.
She did, it was her birthday
and I wanted to surprise my wife.
My wife loves animals, any
kind of animal, she does.
And we work for a preserve
and so I rented an elephant.
I rented an elephant and I
had it brought to the house
because I love her--
- You went big.
- I did go big, but I'm not a good planner
and I have severe attention.
I didn't invite anybody.
I didn't cater.
I didn't bring even a staff.
- So, just like, an elephant showed up?
- Well, let me show you the video
and then I'm gonna talk about the trouble.
So, this is my wife's birthday.
Watch what I did for my wife's birthday.
Watch this.
- [Howie Voiceover] This is
my wife's birthday party.
That's my wife.
Hi wife.
(audience applauds)
There's the elephant.
And there's my wife.
(laughs)
Okay, wait, wait.
(audience applauds)
- That's the saddest party ever.
- There was an elephant there.
- You didn't even have one balloon.
- No, I had nothing and I'm so
stupid, I don't think of this
and also, because we care about animals,
you can't just bring
an animal for an hour.
He had to be out of the transport thing
for at least 12 hours.
So, the animal was in our
backyard for 12 hours.
So, wait, wait.
I don't have that kind of attention
and my wife was bored after a half hour
so we went in the house
but elephants, they like palm trees.
So, the elephant took
out all our palm trees.
The elephant took them
out and laid them down.
And then, the elephant--
- What?
- How much clearer can I make it?
(audience laughs)
And then, the elephant
needed to be comfortable,
so they said I should hose him,
so I hosed the elephant,
which made it muddy
and the the elephant, they're heavy,
the elephant sunk into my
lawn and broke the sprinkles,
all the sprinkler system--
- Happy birthday!
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
And then, I ordered food, not
for us, but for the elephant.
The elephant ate and then the elephant,
is very regular.
The elephant is very regular.
- Oh, my gosh.
- That's what the guy
who came to our backyard the next day said
because there are piles of elephant--
- Dung.
- Poo.
So, the next day, the
gardener, we have a gardener.
Gardener came, comes around the corner,
the yard is these holes
that are four feet deep,
the sprinklers are broken,
five palm trees are
laying all over the place
and there's a pile of...
You can put a bleep on (beep), right?
There's a pile--
(audience laughs)
- Yes.
There's a giant, there is
no, and the guy walks in
and he goes, "Mr. Mandel, what is this?"
and I go, "It was my wife's birthday."
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Nailed it!
(laughs)
- I never explained,
there was $45,000 damage.
The sprinklers, the trees,
- Oh, my gosh.
- And elephant poo removal is
not a service that is nearby.
(audience laughs)
- So your gift to your
wife for her birthday
was just severely
pissing her off. (laughs)
- You know what, I'm consistent.
I'm fairly consistent. (Kelly laughs)
It's not any different on her birthday
than it is each and every day.
- [Kelly] It's important to be consistent.
- You know what she loves about me
is that I'm here and she's not.
(Kelly laughs)
She loves me being away.
- So she gets alone time?
- She gets alone time without me.